Monarch Legacy of monsters is bringing
big monsters to the small screen on
Apple TV plus we've got everything you
need to know about its connection to the
monsterverse its creative father Sun
casting and the Godzilla movies you need
to know about before you watch Monarch
Legacy of monsters was ordered to series
back in January 2022 we finally got our
first glimpse of the project in August
2023 with the release of several promo
images it took a while to get an actual
release date but with the arrival of the
trailer fans finally learned when the
series will land on their screens
November 17th 2023 when Monarch is
finally released it will air on Apple TV
plus we also know the series will run
for 10 episodes which means we're bound
to get plenty of K Kaiju battles and
Citywide
destruction Monarch Legacy of monsters
isn't exactly a prequel or sequel it's
more of a midquel set after the events
of the 2014 Godzilla that blogbuster
flick found Godzilla squaring off
against some overgrown bugs called mutos
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms according to the official plot
synopsis the series will pick up in the
devastating wake of Godzilla's San
Francisco battle against the mutos and
it will focus on siblings following in
their Father's Footsteps they're looking
to discover what their dad's connection
is to the secret organization known as
Monarch the series will be split into
two timelines with one set in the 1950s
and one set to join the
2010s one of the most intriguing things
about Monarch Legacy of monsters is its
impressive lineup of onscreen talent in
a genius bit of casting both Kurt
Russell and his son Wyatt Russell will
be playing the same character army
officer Lee Shaw Kurt Russell is one of
the most famous movie stars in Hollywood
history playing in major films such as
the thing Tombstone and Guardians of the
Galaxy Volume 2 Wyatt also has a pretty
impressive resume acting in projects
such as everybody wants them and Lodge
49 he's probably best known as the
hot-headed John walk ER in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as for the rest of
the cast we'll see annaa of Pinko Fame
and KY Clemens of The Flash they'll be
joined by Andis Holm Joe tippet Eliza
laosi Mari Yamamoto and Hollywood
newcomer Ren WABE it also appears that
John Goodman will be reprising the role
of William rer his character from Kong
Skull
Island just like the Monarch agency is
controlled by very powerful figures
Monarch Legacy of monsters is overseen
by some pretty impressive creatives the
series was developed by the dynamic duo
of Chris black and Matt fraction black
is no stranger to Apple TV plus
Productions having served as an
executive producer on sance and ping the
eighth episode what's for dinner he's
additionally worked on shows such as
invincible and Outcast fraction on the
other hand hailes from the world of
comics along with David aha he created
the comic book run that inspired the MCU
series Hawkeye and he's also worked on
titles such as Uncanny X-Men and the
Invincible Iron Man speaking of Marvel
we know that Matt SharkMan of One
Division and fantastic for fame will be
directing the first two episodes of the
series before Godzilla starts breathing
radioactive flame all over Apple TV plus
you might want to go back and check out
the previous entries in the monsterverse
especially if you want to learn more
about Monarch it all starts with 2014's
Godzilla which gave us one of the most
memorable movie quotes of all time Let
Them Fight the next entry in the series
introduced us to the other major player
in the monster series King Kong taking a
page from Apocalypse Now Kong Skull
Island is a 70 set Vietnam War inspired
Monster Tale that stars huge names like
Tom Heston Brie lson and Samuel Jackson
plus it just might be the best film in
the franchise while it's the most
critically despised of the bunch
Godzilla king of the monsters delivers
on the Kaiju action in fact it brings in
three of the biggest a-listers from
too's impressive creature lineup Rodan
Mothra and King gadora then there's the
Clash of the Titans in God Zilla versus
Kong in one corner you have King Kong
and he is mad and then in the other
corner you have Godzilla and he's mad
what more do we need to
say the theme of giant monsters
destroying their way through
infrastructure and trampling innocent
people in their wake must be a difficult
genre to rate the original Godzilla film
released in 1954 is widely considered a
horror movie however the modern era
monsterverse projects such as the most
recent Godzilla versus Kong are better
classified as action sci-fi projects
with a fitting PG-13 rating so what kind
of family friendliness can we expect
from the monster versus first liveaction
television series Apple TV plus has
given Monarch Legacy of Monsters the
rating of TV y the grading indicates
that the series is appropriate for all
ages Monarch will be a binge worthy
Adventure fit for family night and for
some children who have always been
curious about a giant lizard stomping
their way through a city the Apple TV
Plus show can be their first Glimpse at
the original Kaiju
Godzilla breaking ground Monarch Legacy
of monsters it's rumored to have been
filmed with Apple's latest high-tech
gadgets turns out being funded by one of
the biggest Tech producers in the world
may come with a few benefits for the
series in the summer of 2023 Apple
introduced its new headset the Apple
Vision Pro featuring augmented reality
and a slew of cameras sensors and
unprecedented Computing gimmicks one of
vision Pro's most heavily promoted
features was spatial video which allows
a user to immerse themselves in imagery
and have the perspective change as they
move similar to a hologram shortly after
the technology was announced an apple
Insider indicated on X that Monarch the
legacy of monsters have been filmed with
the spatial video format but as the
release date of the new Apple TV plus
series approaches the company has yet to
officially confirm that it will be
viewable through the Vision
Pro gone are the days when movies
featuring giant monsters were limited to
attacking a city or two and returning to
their respective homes films have gotten
much bigger throughout the years the
these projects appropriately showcase
how a Kaiju monster would have the
entire world turning its head the
monsterverse was one of the first
American projects featuring Godzilla in
which the Beast doesn't limit his
destruction to metropolises like Tokyo
or New York City rather the Lizard King
Kong and the muto Brethren pop up across
the globe throughout the four feature
films it can be expected with global
scale Terror and generation jumping
timelines that Monarch Legacy of
monsters will feature multiple
International settings aside from a few
terrains showcase in the trailer the
filming locations of the series gives us
some Clues as to what and where to
anticipate every time you go to
locations in the show it's a completely
different world primarily Monarch was
filmed in Vancouver British Columbia and
throughout the province of British colia
one Van City local and X shared behind
the scenes shots of the city being
turned into a makeshift army camp
meanwhile the cast confirmed that they
traveled over the Pacific and filmed on
location in Tokyo Japan additionally
showrunner Chris black revealed it in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly that
some scenes were captured on location in
Hawaii it is easy to get caught up in
the thrill of seeing heavyweight
monsters on television but the series is
not named after the biggest baddy of
them all Godzilla for a reason the show
is predominantly about the secret
International Organization known as
Monarch agents of the Men in Black
inspired group pop up around the
Cinematic Universe initially intent on
keeping MOS a secret and protecting the
innocent World from M related
destruction if you watch the four pre
previous monsterverse films and don't
recall much about Monarch's involvement
they are probably doing their jobs
extremely well hopefully a quick
reminder of the organizations's history
will catch you up to speed introduced in
2014's Godzilla Monarch's Origins
stretch back to when big green was first
discovered in 1943 the organization
spent the following decades attempting
to find Godzilla before it helped them
defeat a new mut in 2014 in Kong Skull
Island monar assisted in discovering the
titular Lost Island essentially
uncovering a world of Monsters by 2019s
Godzilla king of the monsters the
organization became public knowledge and
shifted its motives towards a
preservation of the endangered monsters
most recently in Godzilla versus kung
Monarch was at the center of the battle
after moving the giant AE from his
unstable Island Home causing Godzilla to
behave
aggressively a social media account on
EX Monarch scientists has long been a
source of monsterverse content
mysteriously in October 2023 the account
came out of dorcy after 3 plus years
with some Curious messages one of these
read this account no longer belongs to
Monarch And the tagline for the account
was changed to the curiy mysterious it
belongs to the truth soon the rest will
surface additionally an equally
enigmatic website has emerged ahead of
the release of legacy of monsters
Monarch unlocked features some top
secret content linked to the Apple TV
plus series including multiple puzzling
images of Monarch files and projects the
most intriguing document found on the
site is a short video of John Goodman's
car William Randa who first appeared in
Kong Skull Island and is set to reprise
his role in
Legacy Godzilla has a devoted fan base
while not in the same Stratosphere as
other fandoms like Marvel or Star Wars
the following for the big lizard can be
extremely particular with a rich history
of content dating back in nearly 80
years there have been a plethora of
Unique Designs of Godzilla nearly every
iteration of the Titan has come with
subtle changes to the way the lizard
looks Monarch Legacy of monsters will
utilize a gag Goji design for it monster
originally introduced in 2014's Godzilla
the Hollywood version of Godzilla takes
many of its features from dinosaurs
giving the Titan a relatively realistic
presence interestingly there is a
significant process behind getting
Godzilla to look right on screen Gareth
Edwards said it South by Southwest in
2014 I thought it was going to be an
easy job but they did over 100 designs
we kept trying generation after
generation until we landed where we did
you're trying to put out wacky thoughts
and ideas and even if you throw out just
1% of of a new direction that steers the
design in a new way it helps
out if Godzilla isn't enough to get you
breathing fire in excitement for Monarch
Legacy of monsters there have been hints
as to other Kaiju that make an
appearance in the series legendaries
monsterverse has been known to
revitalize classic Toho monsters
bringing beasts like mothur Rodan and
Mecca Godzilla to the big screen still
there is a whole collection of Titans
yet to make an appearance in the
Cinematic Universe is so much more vast
than we could possibly imagine mon Arch
director Matt shakman has already
revealed that many MOS will appear in
the show beyond the King Lizard
meanwhile the trailer and promotion for
the series have revealed a few of the
beasts to expect the Apple TV plus
social media account revealed one
unidentified flying monster additionally
Matt fraction and Chris black spoke to
Entertainment Weekly about a few other
monsters crashing into the first episode
this includes a nightmare inducing giant
spider known as mother longlegs and a
creature described as a giant Titan
version of a crab called mantle claw
finally they had one more trick up their
sleeves with all new insect like MOS
fraction said it was fun to remind the
audience that not all Titans are 400 ft
tall there's danger everywhere of all
kinds of scale and
size with the release of Monarch Legacy
of monsters fast approaching the review
embargo has been lifted resulting in a
swarm of third- party opinions on the
series already Monarch sits at an 89%
Rotten Tomatoes critic score the general
consensus is shaping up to indicate that
the Apple TV Plus show should be worth
the price of admission however most of
the reviews available online come with a
caution sticker for potential viewers a
Critic on/ film wrote Legacy of monsters
is light on the monsters and heavier on
the Legacy stuff those anticipating lots
of Titans smashing through buildings and
roadways should quell their expectations
now instead the series predominantly
features the secret government
organization and the humans trapped in a
world of Titanic beasts still with a
good mix of pacing time jumping and the
odd appearance of the biggest greenest
lizard in pop culture audiences are
certain to get some
entertainment with Monarch Legacy of
monsters still awaiting official release
it is premature to expect a second
season however there are some
indications that audiences can expect
more from the series beyond the 10
episodes of season 1 with the
monsterverse continuing its expansion
with another upcoming feature film
Legacy could stick around to help
continue the universe notably during an
interview with collider director Matt
shakman revealed there may be more to
the legacy of monsters than we will see
in the inaugural season he said it's
when you pitch a show from the beginning
you pitch what's the story of the first
episode what's the story of the first
season and what's the story for the next
5 years that's pretty much expected when
you go to pitch a company like apple of
course things change right you have all
these plans and then you realize that
this is a more interesting Avenue and
things
evolve like a slow and steady gigantic
lizard emerging from the ocean the
monsterverse continues to stomp ahead
since its 2014 Inception Godzilla X Kong
the new Empire set for a 2024 Premiere
will be the next official feature film
from the franchise and will conceptually
work as a sequel to 2021s Godzilla
versus Kong subsequently other projects
have been rumored to be shopped around
behind closed doors at legendary
including a potential son of Kong film
still with fans fully behind the
franchise building further it likely
won't be long before the Titans are
Unleashed Beyond